Now I will turn things over to 3.8 to lead the attack against these bugs.
>> Is everyone ready, Crazy Bob?
>> I am ready, sir.
>> Bite Me? >> Ready to go.
>> Ready to roll.
>> Doctor Bug? >> I was born ready.
>> Oh, excellent.
We are all ready here.
So, let us start.
>> If I could interject something before we begin [LAUGH] I just would like to
say, before we started this project, I I advised management that we wouldn't be
having a lot of these core problems that we've got now if we just use data.
We're on job aid it would really, you know,
it would solve a lot of our integration problems and all.
And I just wanted to make that clear, that I told them before we
began this project that we should do it, and here we are looking at jobs.
So, I just wanted to make that clear before we got started.
>> Well, I mean, with that,
just trying to read this Baloney Code that this guy wrote is unbearable.
>> Well I think we should just, >> I am just sick to my stomach.
>> We should just proceed with the review probably.
>> Oh, well, okay.
>> Gentlemen, let me remind you that I'm the controller here.
[LAUGH] Thank you very much for your advice.
Dear reader, Doctor Bug, please talk.
>> We start with two imports in the code.
The first one is an import to the java.io package, all the classes in
the package, and there's the right semicolon right after that.
And there's another importer, which is to java.lang.System,
which is used for the io, and another semicolon, so this looks fine.
>> So line one, line one is actually not good coding style,
because you should never import you're polluting the namespace.
So we should never import asterisk,
we should only import the classes that we're actually using.
>> Well, I think it's okay, all right, if we need to use multiple ones.
Do you want to spell them all out.
>> But then you're polluting,
you're bringing in all these names that we really don't need.
So, I think it should be, what?
Java. I think the only IO class, let's see InputStream.read, so
we should have java.io.InputStream.reader.
>> I think you're, you're wasting space by doing this,
I mean this is, why is it there?
>> And thanks for telling us about the semicolons, that's a, a big help.
>> Yeah I figured.
>> Can I continue?
>> Yes, please continue.
>> So should I record that as defect or, or we don't believe that's a defect?
>> I think you should I, personally, I gotta,
I gotta echo Crazy Bob here because if we move to the next line here,
purpose, we have the slash star here for comment style and then further on
down we're going to use the slash slash, some consistency would be nice.
>> So, I think we should record that as an error.
>> But let's move on.
>> That's bad style.
>> Sure, sure.
Okay, Crazy Bob will record it.
Dr. Bug?
>> Okay, fine.
okay, then the main class starts, which is >> Before we do that,
let me complain about line 2.
I don't believe you have to import anything from java.lang, right?
I believe java.lang comes in automatically.
>> I believe that's correct.
>> So that's a useless, that's a useless import.
>> Okay, fine, that's what my mentor told me that I was supposed to do but
that's okay.
>> Okay, so then we start with the main classes.
>> Maybe we should reconcile this common issue, before we move on.
As brought up by me.
>> I think so.
>> I mean.
That, that's just.
Don't you have coding standards and
which would include how to write comments in your, in your.
>> I do and it's usually, just stick with one and
then that's the way it goes for the rest of the, the comments.
>> The slash-star has so much history with it.
You know, we want,
we want to reflect the fact that this is a historical artifact.
>> I don't know if I agree I,
I think not only that, I'm not sure what constitutes getting its own white space
like an extra line here.
We move down further maybe we come back to this but
I have a couple places that I marked that I just don't quite understand.
>> Maybe Bite me is saying, let's go one down and come back to this.
Doctor, Bug please continue.
>> Thank you.